i don't know why but we still
give girls dolls and we give boys
to build
things to build and this is horrible
from on on my uh
you know from where i'm standing
um i want to give them a choice by the
way i don't want to tell them you know
you're not supposed to because being an
autistic it's it's important enough but
i want to give them a choice and i think
that at this age that's the
that's the age to start form
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jvengers a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
i am so excited for this episode meet
moran leshombar vice president of global
operations at some paris assigned to
support the continued growth of some
paris global organization
she has been the chief of staff of isar
shai in the ministry of science and
technology since 2020 prior to this she
was the co-founder and ceo of the
largest tech media brand in israel geek
time for 11 years she also co-founded in
2011 the first startup accelerator in
israel venture geeks which successfully
invested in precedence seed and nurtured
startups she served as an instructor in
the computers unit mamram and she
completed her law degree at the college
of management and has been accepted as
an advocate by the israeli bar
association
moran leshambar welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you for joining me right
now from kibbutzafikim
but it's a temporary but thank you for
joining me anyways
uh thank you for having me uh i'm sure
that we'll have fun
we're gonna have a ton of fun i
already have way more questions than we
have time for uh you you're such an
integral part
of the israel ecosystem and in so many
cool ways and right before we started i
mentioned that you know i think one of
the coolest things about the things that
you've done is that you managed to both
operate at a very high scale very
generic across the landscape of the
ecosystem whether it be as chief of
staff with israel shy in in the in the
political scene or with the co-founder
and ceo of geek time one of the main
news channels for tech ecosystem but you
also got to work really hands-on with
companies creating the first accelerator
in israel i think back in 2011
and really working with precedent
companies and obviously today as an
operator role as vice president within
saint peters an amazing amazing company
so you know all around such a balanced
yet amazing
career and and i have to ask you moan
you know if you're looking back at
everything you've done
you know what part do you think you're
playing in this ecosystem here where
what is who is here
so
first of all it's it's kind of neat that
the
this
this all
that i'm having in this ecosystem is
considered to be a
what is it what the word that you were
using like balanced
no not balance but
geeky or fun or like i'm i'm
i feel like i'm i'm making an impact and
while i'm being very
neat and
and you know i'm a geek and i was a nerd
when i was young so it wasn't very cool
to be
those kind of words but now i think that
the you know it's the superhumans
come on guys we're super humans and i'm
also a mother so it makes me a super
super
um human so
i think that uh
to answer your question
um
i think that it was life because
eventually i'm a person that likes to be
in the small details of things
but on the other hand i like to be in
the small details of things of many
things
so it's uh it it's not that i chose my
career but my career chose me
which which sounds like
a cliche but it wasn't it was just you
know how life
turned to be and this is what happened i
met yanni feldman
by accident by the way he was looking
for someone else we started talking and
then we said hey i have some startup
ideas and he said i have some startup
ideas and we will got thrown
through many many stairs
with people that told us guys this is
this will not happen
and then
we wanted to understand who are the main
characters in this ecosystem so we can
approach them it was 200
if i'm not mistaken and you know there
was a there was jose valdez in the
garage geeks
and you know no one heard about startups
no one heard about startups no no one
wrote about startups so we started going
to every event that we could
we could you know hear
hear about and we started meeting people
and it was leg work
and
and then we wanted to go to a ces
and if you want to go to cs you have to
pay lots of money or to be a journalist
uh so we started the vlog to have to you
know that that's just that's a real
story of how news geek or geek time
started
i had no idea yeah we started writing
and then yaniv flew to a ces and i was
very mad with him because we had like
tons of of posts to write
about many different things and he was
like no i'm going to cs and it was a
very hard work only later on we
understood how hard it is to be in these
events like three days in a row and you
do not sleep and you do not eat
and you just write or meet people
and this is how it all started and we
became good friends believable yeah this
is that's the real that's the real truth
behind the
music which turned a big gig
um
we all looked for you know we looked up
to uh techcrunch and the other media
outlets in the in the us
and
eventually we started this one in israel
in hebrew and we got like
so
this you know it wasn't disrespectful
but it was like a big cynical
uh reactions of another another website
why in hebrew every entrepreneur you
know reads in english speaks in english
why do you need it who needs it who is
he who will be interested in it
and you know as as the entrepreneurs we
are we do not listen
and we continue to do what we like to do
and uh and and that's what happened and
by the way microsoft were the first one
who
uh put money on advertising in in usd
because we had like 1 000
users per month that was the beginning
and it was great it was great
um
and then what happened is that our first
investor which is
again by accident he approached us with
via linkedin
um he was my he is my father's cousin
and the last time i saw him before he
invested in us was when i was three
years old and we played marbles together
and he wrote me like hi mohan i see that
you have like news geek and i was uh
interested in
in investing in israeli companies what
can we do
and a month later we had our first
investor
incredible
and one year later we had our first
accelerator because he came to us and
said look guys
look at why uh what it was a y
combinator or the other one i'm not even
sure and he said look we we have to have
this kind of accelerator in israel you
gotta do that
and we said okay but we're only like we
were like five people or seven people in
the company and we hire we uh rented the
floor above us in petra and we've
raised more money to invest
and we invested in five companies no one
knew what an accelerator is we had like
negotiation funny negotiations with
people
and but it you know it happened so i
don't know
as i said it was life i didn't choose it
it
it just happened
no but i but i think if i'm if i
allow myself to draw a pattern and and
the things that you've told me until now
a major pattern here is the fact that
you took opportunities and you embraced
them and you ran with them yes so far
throughout the stories you're describing
opportunities that came to you whether
it's people approaching you or
opportunities that are or new
information that that was open to you
and then your immediate response is okay
let's do it let's roll with it
yeah i think that i like to imagine
things and when i you know i imagined
how it would be uh having a media outlet
and i imagined how it would be to invest
in companies and and help them you know
by the way it was a huge mistake because
we we said we thought that it was it
would be an easy task like we'll invest
the money there'll be
upstairs and you know
they'll work
um we almost lost the company our
company news geek because we had to
invest so much time in in the
five new companies that were forming and
we didn't know that you know it was like
it's
we just started okay we need to help
them with the presentations and what to
tell investors and with their pitch and
with their products and with their
problems and you know please see this
like a huge headache
and and it was first-timers
it wasn't like a
and it's funny because the people that
are now
if i'll tell you the names and i will
not tell you the names they have like
major roles in major companies this is
amazing what happened with them
and and
i'm happy to be there when when they
were so young and it's a relationship
that would last uh forever
it's all about relationships
so
then you decide to do something a little
different and work with the the amazing
izalishai
i didn't decide i didn't decide that
i wanted to take some time off after
leaving a
geek tank because i had i i was there
like for 11 years
so i said okay i'll wait a bit i'll take
a few months off i'm entitled to do it i
want to i want a vacation
and like
two weeks here um i'll tell you the
story it's a funny story because i was
on my way to to uh to take a shower and
i got a
phone call from mizan and it said like
he's all shy and i'm like i'm telling my
my uh uh my wife i was telling her like
look it's his heart and she said like
she was laughing and saying oh maybe he
wants to you know to suggest something
in politics and i was like
no politics for me thank you and i was
answering the phone and he started by
saying look
and i'm i'm
and i'm joining the the government and
i'm searching for a chief of staff and i
thought about you
and
he explained about the world a bit and i
was listening but as as i told you
before i was on my way to to take a
shower and he finished to describe the
the position and and i'm like
is that can i call you back i'm like
i'll take a shower and and i'll call you
back okay i can i can't i need to digest
that
and i called back and i heard some more
and i told him well when do you need an
answer and he said like tomorrow
morning
so i took the
job oh man we worked together and it was
way way way more you can't skip over the
most important piece here
what happened from the moment
he told you tomorrow morning to to the
decision making you were on a vacation
or at least mentally or prepared for a
vacation after 11 years of really really
hard work creating one of the most
amazing media outlets in israel
it can't be a simple decision to jump
into politics which is the least you
know
something you can do this isn't
entrepreneurship at the end of the day
it's like taking risk and doing stuff
like because it feels right and i heard
a lot about him he never invested in me
by the way he said no to to investments
that i that i offered um
and i heard that he was an amazing man
and he sounded amazing and i said look
it's an opportunity to be
to
to to be more influence and influence on
really
uh
on what's going on in the high-tech
industry and in the uh
we were supposed to do that right it was
the the ministry of science and
technology eventually we ended up doing
uh coronal related stuff because these
are took a major role in the in the uh
corona cabinet
so
and then i you know i took all my
knowledge and we started working in with
startups and with the with new ventures
and with apps and i i use all my
connections to assist people
um
in israel the impact is the the impact
was was huge and it was an amazing
experience and i worked 24 hours a day
uh
and night and shabbat and and
it never stops and
and then i said again look um
i need to rest a bit i'm entitled to
and then in shabbat morning i got a
phone call from mickey which is the ceo
saint paris
what's up moan and i'm like oh what's up
like we are friends like long long long
long ago since so long ago and i said oh
great what's up with you and we were
sending pictures of our kids because
he's in new jersey and i'm in israel
and then he started talking a bit more
about what's going on with paris et
cetera
and
and then i said look are you offering me
something are we talking about anything
in particular
your senses are still shocking yeah and
i'm lucky you know yeah yeah and i said
okay let's not make it uh a phone call
for a
foreign let's let's talk a bit more
later
and
this is how that happened
uh once again this is
i think it's about seizing opportunities
that that feels right i
i'm a big believer in intuition
and i'm a big believer in doing stuff
so it was impact here
with what we are doing today because we
have a lot a major impact on on the
economy of the global economy eventually
and it was impact in the israeli
ecosystem with geek time and it was
impacting on israel in in general with
with isaac
and i believe that i'm drawn to these
kind of laws eventually
working in
government or not in government but
working in the political arena
yeah it's different from working with
pre-seed companies and definitely
how do you adapt how do you what what
mental shifts did you have to do in
order to
still be content be innovative be an
entrepreneur in a new organization
yeah so you know first of all when you
work with a minister that is a in his
head is still in high tech it's easier i
must say
because we we get each other
and i think that it was
you know that leaders this is about
being a leader uh leaders are all about
making other people
a
inspired by you by yourself and in in
you know
getting them to do stuff not because you
tell them they need to do it because
they believe that they should do it and
this is politics eventually and this is
what we did there and this is what we
thought that is good for israel and this
is how it happened the minute that i got
there
my major role was
to have this whole office and all this
um
you know amazing people there are
amazing people in the government by the
way
and it was making them all
sure that we are going in the right path
that we are going doing good things
um
and have them join us
and not just tell them like it
i'm not a leader that is like you have
to do it because no
if you think different
tell me i'm listening i listen
and
you know one of the questions that i'm
being asked uh
is is
is what i i what i believe in i believe
in making mistakes and i believe in
uh learning from mistakes and i believe
in uh truth
and i believe in honesty these are the
the major things that lead me
in what i do
so
i think that's the
that's the
this is how it happens i don't i don't
know how to to describe it
fast forward to today
you're working with some paris again now
as a in the company role as vice
president within you know in looking at
operations and globally what what is
your role and and what what challenges
do you come up do you come to solve here
so
do you know the fact that there are
roles that
it all depends on uh how how do you make
them
and what impact do you want to make once
again it's a global role it has impact
on the on the
the company as a whole
we were growing from 35 people to more
than 200
210 people like in in two years this is
a an amazing growth and not just in in
in people's growth we are also growing
with revenues which is amazing but you
need to have a company that can support
this growth and this is where the role
uh comes into place is having the right
platforms is having the right processes
is having the right people uh that will
do it and this is this is eventually my
role it's like it's it's a bit like a a
coo role which is doing what everyone
else is not doing
you know you you know that the the the
the difference so
it's a bit the same
and i'm working with very like uh this
our ceo
shawn valdi
i
look very highly uh
of him amazing person to learn from
and that's the major thing that i i
learn a lot
i do a lot i i have a big impact and
this is what leads me
if there's something that i would ask
you now that you know is in your heart
that you want to do in this ecosystem
something that either is troubling you
because i have the privilege of asking
now somebody who's seen so much of it
and you've been an active part in in so
much of the ecosystem so what if you had
to choose right now one or two things to
tackle
in the ecosystem
what what would they be
so it's easy
easy you know it's not being done
getting more
young girls involved in this ecosystem
and when i say young is in kindergarten
because i don't believe that it starts
later it starts there it starts when you
have to you know they put you and you
choose a doll or something to build and
we have the
i don't know why but we still
give girls dolls and we give boys
to build
things to build and this is horrible
from on my uh
you know from where i'm standing
um i want to give them a choice by the
way i don't want to tell them you know
you're not supposed to because being an
autistic it's it's important enough but
i want to give them a choice and i think
that at this age that's the
that's the age to start from
um so this is the first day and i said
when i'll be in pension that's what i'll
do i'll go from a kindergarten to
kindergarten and i speak to i'll speak
to younger
girls and their parents on on
on how to choose right and and give them
the choice
that's what i want to do
milan it's not that beautiful it's life
insanely insanely inspiring it was uh
not just the last minute but but just
your though your perspective
on your career and
how you're making decisions and it's not
just intuition and just saying yes to
everything it's it's being open to these
opportunities and and thinking about
them very very thoughtfully and you know
take putting aside perhaps preconceived
notions and i guess if i would ask you
if you ever thought that you would go to
politics
when you were in a good time probably
the answer would be no i'm guessing
yeah but i was offered a few times
because because eventually people
people know me but
it's not that's not the the right uh
uh reason to go to to politics you go to
politics when you have the opportunity
to make a difference and i'm not saying
that i will not go will not go back
there
but it will take a few years
and moan i really appreciate you coming
here thank you for the time thank you
for the amazing impact you've had on our
ecosystem
and the impact that you'll continue
making and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak here and
you to stay healthy that's the most
important thing ever now everything else
is like a bonus
[Music]
you